لقد كانا من الضالتين اللتين تم العثور عليهما وهما يتجولان في
شوارع مينيابوليس معًا، واسمهما
بريندا وليندا بعد وصولهما إلى
رعاية الحيوانات في مينيابوليس والتحكم في
أفضل براعمهما، كما تعلم أنهما مرتبطان جدًا ومدى
ارتباطهما لدرجة أنه عندما بدأ ليندا وهانك في
استنشاق بعضهما البعض بريندا
قفزت بينهما على ما يبدو
لتفريقهما ولكن الاختبار الحقيقي جاء عندما
تم وضعهما بجانب بعضهما البعض في بيوت منفصلة
للكلاب وهذا حدث
المهمة المستحيلة، وصفها
الملجأ بأنه من المؤكد أن توم كروز قادر على تسلق الجدران
[موسيقى]
وعادة ما يكون لديه أدوات للمساعدة
قفزت بريندا الجدار الذي يبلغ طوله خمسة أقدام
بمفردها لتنضم إلى ليندا. هل يستطيع معظم كلابك
تسلق جدار بهذه الطريقة؟ لم
يدرك أي عامل في البداية
حدوث شيء ما عندما صدموا لرؤية
مزيجين من بيت بول في بيت واحد لذا قاموا
بفحص الأمن  لقطات كاميرا
ثم رأيت السحر المتمثل في
تسلق الجدار، كان الأمر لا يصدق، لذلك قاموا
بوضع الصديقين معًا في بيت واحد
أكبر للكلاب في معظم الليالي التي مررنا بها وكانا
كما لو كانا في
كرة صغيرة معًا قرر الملجأ
أنه ينبغي عليهما ذلك  يتم تبنيهما كحزمة
معًا، هذا بالضبط ما حدث، حيث قامت
بريندا بسحب مالكك الجديد إلى السيارة
حيث كانت ليندا تنتظر التوجه إلى
منزلها الجديد، وقد لاحظ أحد المعلقين أن
الكلاب الضالة معًا
ليست موجودة في جدار مرتفع بما يكفي للحفاظ
عليها  اثنان منفصلان عن
سي إن إن نيويورك